[Música]
ela já fechou o jornal espera ronel
corte na wii hd você achava que eu nem
poderia ser produzido em hd ora vejam só
eu e hd agora eu escravo que dele sem
que dele sem microfone
vai ficar tudo melhor para fazer
imitações vai dar melhor você escutar
porque você tá demorando tanto a gravar
vídeo veja bem olha isso aqui
não vai construir nada tiver um carro
quebrando um piso ali do lado do meu
quarto meu deus só tem 15 dias que
ficará quebra o piso de chegar ao
flamengo
se você quer um piso tem 15 dias esse
piso está bom desde julho
hoje eu vou gravar um vídeo do filme
amanhã a foto no twitter
se fosse 10.000 rpm gravado então tá
aqui
curiosa o filme começa eles estão dois
cara lá o domínio do leite e outro cara
né que não é protagonista do filme
aparece no filme mesmo sem participação
enquanto assumia toda semana e parecia
um famoso por 11 e assistir o filme só
no comecinho entrei no comércio está
apostando corrida de carros
o filme fala de carro veloz e furiosos
os segmentos e tal mas é um filme sobre
minha volta e ganha do cacon um carro
velho
israel que entrou no carro de maior
vulto fiel pego no estádio falou bonito
no entanto minutos de salomé ter o carro
já estava além disso vai tentar fazer
algum calor dentro do carro faz meia
hora não possui conexão bluetooh dança
lado cantor e botou de ele sair
o que acha graça e se quisermos carro
o carro vai passar por uma calçada
tranquilo acontece é normal e sei que
marca um celta parte de mãe porque furou
no caic em busca de também nunca foi
para casa mas não significa que é bom
vai ficar muito bem ele fala unido toda
hora passando o para baa1 dito por um
lado está conseguindo passar de mim ou
mas o que eu vou fazer um bonito gol o
motor do carro velho aguenta mais o
talento começou a pegar fogo
o fogo começou a subir no carro na mão
do goleiro gilson passado para ver se
chega na nave foi um começo eu não
aguento um segundo de fogo no cauc curto
faz quando o carro já tô a fim de
dirigir o carro de remédio nitro que
mede a ré e começa a dirigir diretas ou
trocar fácil ganhar do cara corrido de
renan carro velho sem sim pegando fogo
não se estacionar um carro autoria
corridas todos não importa motores na
mulher dele depois de uma volta de carro
ela furiosa de carro que é nossa
filosofia de capacho a faca utilizada
nos carros e para o ano nesse carro novo
carro todo mundo inclusive fechado mas
as conversas não discuta nintendo casa
em um gol não só usam que hajam ela
arrecada muito a metais o café chamá lá
dá para escutar mais nada a gente mesmo
essa redação do livro papa vai englobar
a raiva da gente ouve está fechada
falar da [ __ ] sai 16 roubado que ele
está na minha frente pouco e ainda quer
reclamar né
[Música]
oi hoje o não pode passar pelo bella da
[ __ ]
não vou falar estragada que fosse um
filme que o torito ele fica do mal e do
mal para um motivo entendeu e quando vou
dizer que e aí que a história começa
porque o derrote o de rock está ligado à
derrota de rock rola
o motivo também vou falar aqui mas na
cadeia de rock funk lá na cadeia ele
encontra aquele cardoso no anterior que
eles brigaram ligado e meter a porrada
isso aqui de frente um torno de moda de
rock fala assim é que eu não consigo
fazer bonde onde eu saí daqui último
ataca imagina voz grossa na cabeça do
outro o outro do marfim o time ataca
também eu sei que ele pode pegar os
times vão sair na porrada quando este
mapa ainda o melhor da programação da
porta do presídio todas as pontes do
pedido abc sai todos os bandidos cá mais
perigoso do mundo meu amigo vai liberar
mazé bom estoque goleiro pronto não sai
começa a correria nem água corrente
batem se matando até no marcador parecia
fortalecer a no castelão já chegaram
poderosos policial combate borracha nos
preocupar com o que deixava balabina
suspeitos e policial vinha correndo
para voar em todo mundo são todos já têm
todo mundo os carros e regar a faculdade
santa vai pegar o carro mal a polícia
cerca de domínio e estão fazendo a iata
dominada e depois oscar vão ter que
procurar o autor e tu que está
desaparecido na líbia ou do mal né tá
fazendo serviço do mal então a galera
toda dólares curiosa tem que procurar o
autor e as galvão a reunião neto lá de
boa na reunião vamos conversar sobre
como a gente vai procurar autoria da
explosão da [ __ ] mundo inclusive no meu
beijo jogo a derrota para uma bomba e
uma bomba com a mal é o segundo a bomba
não tão seguro de são joão que assegura
uma bomba na minha moto e de carro total
com os carros por hora de brasília a
manaus brasília teresina e maceió
a tecnologia dos carros e os carros são
estacionados em cima do shopping assim
sabe para que o estacionamento do
primeiro andar para andar quatro pisos
buscar começa a pular andar sozinho e
cai a primeira vez que vi na minha vida
um carro se dá a céu está envolvido
nessas coisas então vai falar de rock
vaga lá toda vez que consegue autor e
comércio que as corridas de carro que os
carros nas ruas não quebre a ferrari não
sei que bate no muro no albergue não tem
nada aqui falar
reduzir a nada o tao bom esses cabeça
bom mas joga não tem medo de nada não
sei como é que o povo nos deu num do
dossel fazê-las curioso submarina embora
aqueles barulhos bola corre bateu nos
outros ninguém bom eu quero aquele
embora de gelo de autopeças no gelo tem
carro todo jeito no gelo não entendem a
lama tomou do lamborghini ferrari
o gelo não que o carro é bom em especial
ela vai casar mas que arrasta com 11
horas
estou sem ar mas sim com os quatro golos
feito nos peitos pedrada no peito e
soltou uma pancada tão grande mas também
lembrei da minha mãe com essa pancada do
gênero musical love furiosos legado
doloroso que ia de carro que bateu o
sindicato estadual pedindo valores
curiosa e meu deus acabou o filme acabou
que eu consegui mashego de rock num
carro top das cenas mais linda que eu já
vi na minha vida eu quebrar o pescoço de
um cara com um veja bem não foi com
paulo foi concorrente não foi um colete
foi com um barco da como the rock é top
é uma cena que para minha lápide da top
se do de rock que não tem condição mesmo
buscar lã sumiço mil
isso sai assim da água que é um mito
submarina garrafa d'água segundo filme
explica a cirurgiã se ao tipo de
encontro com a galera do velozes e
furiosos que vai matar galera lá os
curiosos e ficar com o meu irmão o de
rock sai do carro e desvia o míssil com
a mão quem o torpedo com a mão torpedão
aí aí nenhum e acabou com a mão
olha só clicar aqui e gostei aqui
embaixo aqui no youtube tem muita gente
que sai e quando vi já que fecha não tem
que primeiro gostei tá eu quero que você
comece aqui embaixo qual outro filme que
você quer que eu faça digão assistir
porque vai ter vários filmes massa que
vou sair em dia comenta aqui embaixo de
interrogação porque eu vou assistir
vídeo aqui é nóis valeu valeu e